this episode of congratulations is
brought to you by blue apron and that is
the number one fresh ingredient and
recipe Delille delivery service in the
country for less than $10 per person per
meal blue apron delivers seasonal
recipes along with pre-portioned
ingredients to make delicious
home-cooked meals blue apron knows your
bid it busy so now they are offering
30-minute meals which is great it's
great for me because these meals are
made with the same flavor and farm-fresh
ingredients you know and love and
already in 30 minutes or less I don't
have time neither do you so this is a
good thing if you don't have it get it
check out this week's menu and get your
first three free get your first three
meals free with free shipping by going
to blue apron dot-com slash Congrats
blue apron a better way to cook this
episode is also brought to you by the
cash app you guys get this thing I don't
know if you've seen this but the cash
app has done something amazing they've
introduced the cash card it's a new
black debit card that you can design
yourself via the app it's very cool I've
seen it and I like it the cash card
allows you to use the cash that you keep
in the app anywhere you want it's really
awesome
I'll talk about this more later on in
the show download the free cash app for
iOS or Android now what's up my babies
how are you it's congratulations the
podcast we're back we introduce some new
this this past week of the Maurice
Nicoll white episode but if you haven't
heard it it is the that that is the name
of Michael Caine I tell you I've thought
more that's Michael Caine's real name
I've thought more about Michael Caine
this week than I ever have in my entire
life and because of how hard I was
laughing in the last episode and about
Michael Caine's website and so many
people were tweeting me stuff about
Michael Caine's website and one thing I
did not mention last week was that when
you click on the pictures of microwave
Kings gallery there the
[ __ ] same size as they were are
already as the thumbnails fix it
so yeah and but we introduced something
new and that is the video so if you're
just listening to this go back and start
last week and watch the video of the
podcast and it starts with episode 32 so
we're trying it out we're seeing if you
like it so far the the it's been a
positive whatever positive feedback
about it and I'm just trying to grow
this thing man if you're not helping me
grow it you stallin and what I mean is
you're stalling not stalling the general
or whatever he was but you're stalling
of the the growth of my cult of you know
what you're stalling the growth of our
cult and that's not cool you know if
you're not growing you're stalling if
you're stalling you're dying
okay now I am fresh off of the plane
from Tempe Arizona I was in Phoenix and
Tempe which is should be the same
goddamn thing Phoenix and Tempe is same
place is this AK same place you step one
way Phoenix you step another way Tempe
the same goddamn place and I love I
think Tempe if I had to narrow it down
but and I'm not talking about New York
Boston LA you know big although Phoenix
is a big city but when you're talking
about like the coastal cities I always
like going there because it makes me
feel like if I need to and [ __ ] went
down I can get on a ship and go
somewhere else
even though wouldn't ever do it wouldn't
ever be on the ship but if some [ __ ]
went down I could I have the option have
the option but I think I would say Tempe
is my favorite place to go perform the
crowds are always awesome and the
temporary improv specifically is just
great the crowds are awesome and this
weekend
was the crowds were awesome they were
just great they were jacked I have a lot
of new material and I'm building it so
it's like it's making me feel good I'm
feeling good about performing again not
that I didn't earlier but I got you know
I was doing that man on fire set for so
long that now it feels good to like do
new [ __ ] and get it going and discovered
what I want to talk about now I don't
know if it'll be part of my next special
but it's fun to talk about it's fun to
do it and fun to figure it out and it
makes me feel like I don't know you have
to start all over from scratch so I did
that in Tempe I played also Phoenix
stand up live Tempe was so hot man it's
so hot even now in September but I mean
I guess it's still technically summer
but I guess you don't know but uh it's
summer ish and there it's definitely
summer it's too hot man and I've said
this before but don't be that hot and
and not have bubble constrictors around
okay cuz Stu ha and and it's such a
college town which is cool that they
come out to the show but sirillium
knowin how much they love their football
and let me you know straight up khuda
okay for sure if you like that much
football they're the dev they're the Sun
Devils or some [ __ ] dumb [ __ ] like
that you know Sun Devils I don't know
are they the Sun Devils hey you know
[ __ ] is that you can't just like put two
words together and make it cool like
that and now you're the Sun Devils and
then all these [ __ ] people are like
[ __ ] go Sun Devils you know you know
in a [ __ ] arena but yeah and yellow
and maroon are their colors sug ly a
McDonald's dude you're gonna give me
fries and a Big Mac no cool change your
colors you
making me hungry
is called Frank cush field you dude
hey dude it's Frank Kush field deed no
uh I don't I wouldn't want a statue of
me period anywhere you know how people
are like oh we get a more to light that
seems like some old school [ __ ] I guess
there's the [ __ ] I guess that's him
there's a statue of some [ __ ]
football player in bronze on Arizona
State I wouldn't I wouldn't want it is
famous is you you could be as a comedian
and I don't even know there are probably
some statues of some comedian somewhere
but that's just like some old school
[ __ ] that they you would do you know
like ah we would immortalize you with a
stone statue like go [ __ ] [ __ ] off
just remember me do it put me on the
internet somewhere you know that you
know let like the copper benches that
they have and then they'll have like a
[ __ ] guy sitting on the bench like a
[ __ ] coppers the part of the bench
like he was made [ __ ] with flames and
fire and they put a guy with a business
suit on the bench and like he's like
reading a paper or some goddamn [ __ ]
like what are you doing dude you know
what I want on that bench instead of
that guy room because if there's [ __ ]
three people sitting on the bench and
then I gotta watch some wrought iron
[ __ ] [ __ ] that was honored
by sitting on this bench that I have no
[ __ ] idea who it is and I gotta eat
my [ __ ] salad standing up and I can't
sit down and eat it on my lap at this
beautiful park that I should be enjoying
myself leisurely at then you know what
remove the statue statues don't get to
sit they're statues they don't need to
rest by I want to [ __ ] statue in my
bed just laying down so I can cuddle
with a [ __ ] wrought iron dude that
like built an important [ __ ] building
somewhere
also how many of them are asks a bad
dude how many of them have faith
remember the Ronaldo one where he was
like two years so I mean dude cross-eyed
all of his features too close together
and also doesn't look like him at all
dude
when they when they photoshopped his
face to look like the statue that was
the best and they kept doing it over and
over again
god damn whoever did that literally
should have [ __ ] killed themselves
they'll probably also got death threats
over that and there's no way you can't
do anything negative about soccer Andres
not received death threats people from
Barcelona will be like hey well you do
why you [ __ ] around huh why are you
[ __ ] around
we impale you don't don't make statues
anymore just it's not and and then
there's all the other [ __ ] where then
now they want to pull them down about
the [ __ ] you know died due to fight a
statue when they're trying to pull down
the [ __ ] racist statues or whatever
the [ __ ] and they're like no that's our
of history like they're [ __ ] statues
dude you know it's a statue you know
what they should have done they should
have taken those statues of [ __ ]
robert e lee or whatever was it was i
who was and [ __ ] bended his knees and
just sat him on a [ __ ] park bench so
near in a racist town so racists
couldn't sit down at their park that's
what they should have done and they
would have been like oh man I'd love to
sit down but no we gotta [ __ ] paintin
we got a [ __ ] wrought iron robbery
Lee sitting down we got to see we gotta
respect that
while we sit on his lap knee in our
salad our fried salad they'll fry
anything in the south they'll be like
you ever tried fried [ __ ] cereal
you're like huh you try it you'll see
you ever try fried bacon yeah yeah well
have you ever tried fried ice cream huh
oh you tried you'll see you chopped
fried ask him how's that work you fry
[ __ ] ice cream yeah but how's it work
as it's cold you just [ __ ] do it
oh cool you ever [ __ ] sign a fried
document
it'll are you we got [ __ ] we lawyer
up make you sign a fried document [ __ ]
yeah
you'll sign a goddamn fried doc you man
you ever put on a fraud suit what
hell yeah you're looking tastier than a
[ __ ] boy with your fried tie and
fraud suit fraud belt fried [ __ ]
loafers put on this fried type hat boy
you looking tastier than the
[ __ ]
oh you looking tasty put on this fried
Mont Monica what do you call it [ __ ]
monocle put on a fried monocle yeah you
get that grease in your eye boy you look
guys looking tastier than the
[ __ ] I don't know how I started
talking about ASU and wound up on Friday
monocle
but dude ASU you know is there more of
Ecology college than ASU Sun Devils dude
[ __ ] Sun Devils and and I walk down
Mill Street which is like the street
where all the college kids are and
there's like that
I love the college towns that have that
college shop we're like you can buy
anything but it has the mascot on it you
know like literally you can buy shirts
or pants or like shoes or hats but also
a [ __ ] like like condoms with like a
[ __ ] badger on it you know and or
like like notebooks and textbooks and
you'd have like the Bourne Identity
trilogy with a [ __ ] badger on it it'd
be like come on you get the bluedevils
Bourne trilogy they get that oh they got
number one fingers goddamn those number
one fingers dude who ever [ __ ] made
that big ass foam number one finger is
equally as genius as they are [ __ ]
the biggest [ __ ] of all time to even
think of that idea you gotta be dumb as
[ __ ] but then also capitalize on other
people's dumbness to get that [ __ ]
finger if you're over if you're under
you know 14 fine but if you're [ __ ]
30 or 50 and you have one of those foam
cores like that she's doing with your
life you live life wrong and you know
what deep down you know it so here's
what you do
you take that finger you'll water it up
real nice
you [ __ ] stick in a pool or you run
it under the sink you put it in the
freezer you let it harden up then you
take it out hours later or the next day
you put it directly on the ground and
then you sit on it let that cold finger
go right up janus don't do don't have
the foam finger
if you do it should be up your ass cuz
that's what you deserve
let that foam finger go directly let
that hard foam frozen finger go directly
up your ass cuz that's what you deserve
that's what you deserve
man I don't like rooting you know I
don't like rooting hey hey here we go
no hey hey here we go we can't you can't
stop us no one can then oh yeah you can
yeah yeah you can't stop us no one can
edit that down yeah you can yeah you can
people can stop you armies bunch of
strong guys can stop you once you're
stronger guys can stop you
chemical warfare can stop you hey you
can't stop us no I can't then and then
and then [ __ ] fighter jets just oh my
god I guess we're stuck oh god oh god oh
god he's missing his leg [ __ ] dumbass
cheerleaders you can't stop us no again
[Music]
my god you know I made a love stop stop
he knows you know oh my god
oh my god Katie's holding her sorry her
stomach's going out you can't stop us no
one can accept fighter jets and Giants
Giants cuz I percent the parent that
that dude I don't like that whole
[ __ ] you can't stop us bears can it
literally bears could if Aris came and
ate us up the Bears get stopped by dint
that Dan and then think that that's my
cheer dude I would have a [ __ ] I'm
gonna I won't want to get a college just
so I can [ __ ] get real good football
players real good football players maybe
we're number three or some [ __ ]
or like by the way [ __ ] all these
divisions you know what I mean
oh yeah we're Division two we're
Division one we're Division three nah
[ __ ] that get rid of divisions all play
each other don't give a [ __ ] okay play
each other your division one in Division
five if you Division five you suck [ __ ]
you're in Division one and you're and
you're a hundred and seventy at the
place that's what you are swatch are and
then [ __ ] I want to get a football
team I want to get a college I'm gonna
get a football team and then I want a
wow I really I don't even have a [ __ ]
clue what I was trying to get at and
then and then oh I don't want to have oh
oh that's what I want I want to have the
cheerleaders and I want the cheerleaders
to be [ __ ] you know really good at
what they do and doing all the twists
and doing the one thing where you flip
up the there's guys to where they flip
up the girl and hold them on one foot
for some reason even though it's not
necessary even though you never need to
do that
and then and then and then I want the
cheers to be like we can almost not be
stopped we your number three in the
league there are a few things gets that
can stop us and then when girls like
bears and then the other girl goes
fighter jets and then animal goes
chemical warfare didn't one goes like if
we didn't have enough oxygen
yeah and then the [ __ ] idiots with
the big [ __ ] golden helmets with that
[ __ ] what is this thing this [ __ ]
the Spartan there's always some [ __ ]
even if it's not they're not the
Spartans there's some [ __ ] with a
[ __ ] French horn that's like Rome and
he's got a fur [ __ ] helmet mom and
there's a dumb goofy badger just like
jumping around
hey how [ __ ] dumb is what I'm
describing and here's the worst part
it's real it's not a dream I'm not
describing a dream I had
people cheering around you can't stop us
no one can and a big goofy [ __ ]
badger doping around and people with
number one finger hands foam and then
some [ __ ] guys playing the French
horn ramp dump rembrandt prompt and then
guys [ __ ] come out and burst out of
paper not impressive when they [ __ ]
burst out of paper and they're not
impressive and then you got the [ __ ]
band leader hey band leader don't need
you hey band leader grab an instrument
get behind everyone the guy who just
steps put it in your [ __ ] and maybe
he's got a flute or some dumb [ __ ]
try harder what the [ __ ] is that what is
this what is that guy Ohio State drum
major tryouts hey dude don't try out
that just pick someone also don't have
it at all what is he doing
drum major oh oh it's so hot on the
ground so hot on the ground he's
stepping so look at this [ __ ] this
guy's got parents look at this guy he's
got parents dude I'm looking at a guy if
you're not watching the video twirling
around a baton so casually dude like
he's literally twirling around like not
doing nothing not doing nothing at the
end of it oh man can you do that and be
straight I mean I mean you could and
it's happened before but how about that
what is that what did they call that
color guards oh man he does fantastic
moves you know what my favorite thing is
and when it when when the drum major
like drum major [ __ ] or even when a
guy's playing drums one of the funniest
things to me is imagine no music no
sound anywhere except you can hear him
and he's going drum major is the
bandleader hi bye
hey you're a bandleader bye you don't
need to lead the band just have the guys
play the instruments and trolly all
around it doesn't matter do it we are
number one didn't did then then nothing
to really stuff us we know when they
throw the [ __ ] baton up so high and
they have to look at it and watch it
like a [ __ ] until they catch it what
are you doing what are you doing what
you doing with your lie that's amazing
actually to be a bandleader and wear a
cape dude and wear the Pope's hat what
the [ __ ] if you have any feathers on you
just run yourself through a carwash you
know you got gold ropes on your head put
them round
your neck time on a pole jump ah I mean
are enough of this [ __ ] but yeah man I
mean I just described something that's a
real thing
like not dreams like is is it like stop
routing I don't know it is what it is
but all that [ __ ] me and I'm it now
me and Amy many many many many and
people like what kills me is like like
it's so alpha to [ __ ] be like sports
[ __ ] yeah [ __ ] yeah but that's not alpha
it's so secretly beta if you're [ __ ]
rooting for sports its beta and it's
fine to do it but your beta you're not
an alpha you beta because you're rooting
for other dudes to run it through the
[ __ ] Gold Line also you're playing a
gaming if you're playing you're playing
a game that other people created smile
fuh you secretly beta you know the
[ __ ] true alphas are crazy people
[ __ ] insane [ __ ] that are
like screaming and coffee shops nobody's
doing that [ __ ] you're the man guys that
are just [ __ ] in like IKEA just like
there's no more tree bark does it get
insane [ __ ] science is
everywhere science is everywhere that
guy is a [ __ ] alpha oh you think he's
gonna pick up a ball and get teammates
beg the [ __ ] out of here with your betas
[ __ ] that guy's the man he's alpha the
guy that'll just
[ __ ] take his pants down and pull on
his [ __ ] in like an in-and-out burger
that guy's the [ __ ] he's alpha dude um
yeah you're alpha and you out there
[ __ ] you know in the locker rooms
just [ __ ] you said put it inside me
no touchdown
okay well [ __ ] yeah it sounds like I was
beaten up by like football players I
wasn't I just [ __ ] I'd rather be the
guys screaming out in a coffee shop
there's no more tree bark or Sciences
everywhere then throwing a ball to my
teammate yeah and and that's what's up I
don't any song you know what songs are
the worst this is I was watching [ __ ]
I'm so tired of the [ __ ] shows on TV
especially Network TV when it's like
when the music dictates how you're
supposed to feel about the scene when
it's like two doctors are flirting with
each other but it's like light flirting
and nobody died in the episode yet
because it's the [ __ ] 25th minute in
and it's like limping limping then I'm
dumb man I'm pumped um and the girls
like trying to flirt but her [ __ ]
hair is messed up um hey Ken hey how's
it going Carla oh nothing about that
surgery huh sure yeah good thing you
didn't die huh yeah we're doctors big
gamble wait boom and then the other
nurse walks up that was your best try
huh yeah man only been rampant and but
um you know then she just goes and blows
her [ __ ] hair off her face
oh [ __ ] that that's been a scene 75
times it's been a scene in every doctor
show
mm mm mm mm mm well yank Hey
oh whoops love getting in the way of
cars it's kind of a thing here bang
until an amp they ring yeah yeah okay
Carla track - that's the [ __ ] nurse
that walks up she's always watching that
I'm dumb thing gonna link then Hey so
great food here at the cafeteria huh
yeah I guess if you like frozen meat
yeah no I mean I didn't really mean it I
just Carla you sure don't say what you
you what you mean a lot yeah I can no I
know it's kind of like one of my things
whoops drops the tray yelling and
thumping and him pimp them I've ketchup
on my shirt dump them then the nurse
walks up you're gonna eat that madam
pimping [ __ ] off dude you can't do it no
one can the cheerleaders are there you
got ketchup on your [ __ ] shirt you
can't do it no one can
another person could do it but this is
the script into the pen pant pant the
bed but they in it
fighter jets over the hospital
come on dude try harder stop being
formulaic goodbye can a baby drink you
stop being formulaic in a newborn drink
yeah
stop being from [ __ ] man
here we go me undies look you want to
look good in your underwear right you
want to be comfortable cool check check
but that perfect balance is hard to
follow it's hard to find
sacrifice style or comfort check out me
and ease calm and find the best pair of
underwear in the world my undies will be
the most comfortable pair of underwear
you will own take it from me I'm telling
you I got them they are they're made
from sustainably sourced naturally soft
fabric that is three times softer than
cotton you put it on feels like butter
around midsection okay for the fellas me
undies diamond seam pouch cradles you
jewels and gives your stuff the support
it needs without feeling too tight okay
it still breathe right now me undies has
an exclusive offer just for my listeners
get 20% off your first pair and free
shipping satisfaction guaranteed money
back if you don't like them me undies is
sure you'll love their underwear they
even offer our 100% satisfaction
guarantee
alright so it's a no brainer try 20% off
free shipping and 100% satisfaction
guarantee what you waiting for huh do it
you get 20% off free shipping and their
100% satisfaction guarantee my undies
calm / Congrats that's my undies dot-com
stash Congrats
limited time offer what are you waiting
for start wearing the best underwear of
your life it honestly changed my life in
the underwear Department it's time to
get me undies to change yours go to my
undies calm / Congrats right now blue
apron is the number one fresh ingredient
and delivery a recipe delivery service
in the country blue aprons mission is to
make incredible home cooking accessible
to everyone and guess what they did it
they set the highest standards for
ingredients and they build a community
of home chefs you want to be one be one
blue apron has established partnerships
with over 150 local farms fisheries and
ranchers across the United States as a
result seafood beef chicken pork produce
it's all raised and made better blue
apron ships the exact amount of each
ingredient required for a recipe so it's
easy you guys can do this upcoming meals
our summer vegetable and egg paninis
with Calabrian chili mayonnaise and
caprese salad garlic butter shrimp and
with green bean salad and roasted purple
tomatoes can't say it without
mouth-watering that's just some of the
stuff blue apron knows you're busy so
they're offering 30-minute meals which
is what I like these meals are made with
same flavor and farm-fresh ingredients
you know and love and already in 30
minutes are left
less so check out this week's menu and
go to your first get your first three
free meals with free shipping by going
to blue apron dot-com / congrats you
will love how good it feels and tastes
to create incredible home-cooked meals
with a blue apron so don't wait blue
apron com / Congrats blue apron a better
way to cook yeah Nene in finding a guy
likes a girl rink you know it's what it
is but that's how it is
musical kit musical get you you know
what the best though the war I think how
about when people like you know what's
so funny is a dust and so out of style
is crooning but there's still always
like that one guy that like makes it
you're a dame just a guy I love how like
our shucks they are I'm just a guy like
yeah we know man you're just too good we
think you were a [ __ ] transformer no
metal parts just a guy you're a gal if
any song cost someone a gal sexist
I love how underlying ly sexist crooning
is you know I'm a guy I matter more than
you
Oh get under me on your knees start
gargling start gargling put my nuts in
your mouth start gargling you're a girl
you matter less than me put me above you
start gargling gargle gargle you gotta
wanna keep on gargling gargle gargle if
you stop all punching the basement put
on the fluffy dress don't show too much
ankle or you're a [ __ ] oh my god if you
show another guy your knees if you show
another guy your knees you're a goddamn
[ __ ] gargle gargle I'm taller and much
stronger
we're under and they don't start that
way you know they start beautiful we're
we're both on over and under the Paris
moon one look in your eye one one look
in your eyes I realize I'm just a guy
a manly woman ah you're a gal cook for
me [ __ ] gargle gargle get inside let me
look at the moon some more gargle gargle
I need alone time make me some sausage
[ __ ] give me starches and carbs now
gargle we don't know the health benefits
of eating greens give me brown food
give me beige food that's all I'm eating
this is the forties oh you're cooking
standing up why are you doing that get
lower [ __ ] get lower [ __ ] I matter
more your cheeks are rosy keep them pink
keep them pink if not I'll give you like
taps on the cheek that's smooth the
songs were so sexist back then dude get
in a line I'll pick my mate let me go to
work and so you socialize read a book or
something
but don't get too smart gargle gargle I
butch in your place if you tell me
something in public like the croonin
[ __ ] but now it can't be like that you
know you got like Martin Michael Buble
that so secretly wants to be that way
but isn't that way you know like he
can't sing about the real [ __ ] so he'll
just be like you're lovely like that'll
be a song it's just called your lovely
her eyes her hair she's lovely
she's lovely you're the only one right
for me and you could see in his head and
his face just like goddamn [ __ ] [ __ ]
is there an
it was Harry Connick jr. remember when
chicks loved Harry Connick jr. because
that move that's the music was so out of
[Music]
out of fashion and then he came in with
his like scruffiness and is like goofy
but also handsome ass [ __ ] and girls
were like oh my God he's just singing
about me but secretly he was singing
gargle gargle you know hey his name's
Harry Connick jr. you know remember when
he was in some [ __ ] movies like hope
floats never watched that movie that
name of that movie hope floats hope
floats dude it might as well be named
the diarrhea Chronicles
that's the worst title of any fucking's
and I've never seen the movie no clue
what it's about
I guarantee somebody has a disease in it
and it's like [ __ ] so it's like sad
look at what it's about isn't birdie
which is her name in it which [ __ ]
gargle gargle don't have a lead
character named birdy it's too cute no
one will be named that and if every if
anybody was named that in real life
everyone would hate him [ __ ] that name
birdy you [ __ ] dumb [ __ ] somebody
wrote down birdy okay Sandra Bullock is
an unassuming housewife oh that's weird
they made a movie about somebody
unassuming whose life is disrupted when
her husband Michael pair Parakh reveals
his infidelity or on a Ricki Lake style
talk show okay she goes home to her
mother
general uns and the small town in which
she grew up where everyone knows of her
televised marital collapse meanwhile an
old friend Justin Connick jr. of course
he's there has entered her life
sparkling romance while Justin's
intentions are clear and good birdie
struggles with decisions to let him
fully into her life and one of them is
for sure dying even though it's not
happening they didn't they cut that part
out somebody was [ __ ] dying of like
you know
hey oh there we go
right there okay there we go right there
she also tries to rebuild her
relationship with her estranged mother
her ailing father father who suffers
from Alzheimer's disease and we knew it
because it was predictable so gargle
gargle and and you know there's a scene
where he's on the [ __ ] hospital bed
and he's like birdie you gotta let him
oh you gotta let him in you gotta let
him in you're only doing yourself an
injustice gargle gargle and then Carrie
Connick made a song and and Harry
Connick how much was he just I would
he's probably not he seems like such a
good guy but I just wish he was a
deviant just singing stuff like big
beautiful blue boulders and then at
night he was just like I don't care what
[ __ ] it doesn't matter I don't have big
tits that would be so funny to me oh man
you know all these [ __ ] movies that
that that Harry Connick jr. was in was
about him and a woman who was either
ailing or had an ailing [ __ ] cousin
or dad or some [ __ ] and now he's got a
show called the Harry Connick jr. show
and it's the most amazing thing I've
ever seen in my life they'll be like we
got a guy who plays a piano on coming on
later and then the girl played the piano
and he'll be like what oh and then other
people be like in the housewives just
like and he's like we put them keys like
that and he'll just [ __ ] kick his leg
up and then the house hazards being they
have to go home and change their pants
because they're all wet cousin made him
mmm cuz cuz you turn them on cuz the
husband's always working and they want
to be with that goofy scraggly hair face
haired [ __ ]
crooner when even though he's [ __ ]
probably at home she's like mm-hmm
and then he wakes up a beautiful day get
out [ __ ] gargle gargle um
no he honestly seems like a [ __ ]
great guy for real I'm just I'm just
having some fun just having a laugh he
was an Independence Day the first one
and then they remade it 20 years later
uh and he wasn't in it but uh yeah but
that then and then [ __ ] man you heard
about this tracker app tracker it's
everything
wallet phone keys wallet phone keys why
does leaving the house always turn into
the world's most annoying scavenger hunt
I hate it I can't find stuff
eight years ago tracker changed
everything when they released their
first tracking device and now they've
done it again with the all new tracker
pixel you'll never worry about losing
your things again you could put them on
anything tracker pixel is the lightest
Bluetooth tracking device on the market
you put it on whatever you intend to
lose keys wallets you cat you can put it
on it's small enough to fit anywhere
when you misplace an item that has
tracker pixel attached use your
smartphone and a 90 decibel alert will
help you find it in seconds it even has
powerful LED lights so you can find
anything even in the dark you lose your
phone just press the button
phone rings even if it's on silent
locate your item if it's miles away
every tracker uses the user is a part of
the largest crowd locate network in the
world
30 days money-back guarantee you got
nothing to lose get the tracker dot-com
/ Congrats go to tracker go to the
tracker dot-com / Congrats it's the
tracker dot-com / congrats and get 20%
off any order that's V th e TR a CK our
comm / congrats for 20% off the tracker
dot-com / Congrats
square cache everyone is switching to
the cash app because it's literally the
best way to pay people back friends
family coworkers Harry Connick jr. it
doesn't matter michael buble sending and
receiving money is totally free and fast
and most payments can be deposited into
your bank account directly in seconds
you download the square cash app you
link your debit or credit card select an
amount to send and type in a friend's
phone number or email address to
complete a payment and they'll get a
notification that they just received
money that's it no gimmicks Square cash
is better than the other apps it is it's
not a social network alright you don't
need to have people know when you're
paying somebody back for sushi right now
let's talk about this new cash card it's
a new black debit card that you can
design yourself via the app you're
creative you can do it yourself the cash
card allows you to use the cash that you
keep in the app anywhere you want you'll
get notifications for all payments made
with the card directly via the cash app
you can laser etched your card to
personalize it and it will be delivered
directly to you for free you like laser
etching or you were you like some guy
who doesn't like laser etching I like
everything that has to do with laser
laser so do this with me the cash app
team is constantly building awesome new
features also so if you thought this
laser etched thing was the N yeah right
beginning
what are you doing using the other guys
get cash app today switch like I did
download the create free cash app for
iOS or Android now if not then you know
what you can do gargle gargle you know
what the worst kind of music is though I
think period scatting what is it what
are you doing
you just feelin it yeah but bad yeah but
that that does you be the bow what bam
bam and bam bam hey man you're a [ __ ]
fool we Benny wait when they do that one
we yawn a swingset scat singing vocal
jazz vocal jazz take everything about
jazz that's amazing room
move it wordless vocables vocal
improvisation with wordless vocables
nonsense syllables this is from
Wikipedia or without words at all in
scat singing the singer improvises
melodies and rhythms using the voice as
an instrument rather than a speaking
medium aka the dumbest [ __ ] thing you
can do well I look bad bad blue
bow-wow-wow Avenue Babu Wow bad bad
shove it up there we pbbt imagine
somebody doing that seriously and
actually thinking that this is good I'm
a scatter what do you do oh I scat I'm a
scatter oh yeah isn't that what also is
like isn't that like also like guys
[ __ ] on someone's chest scatting
like in Germany or did I just totally
make that up hey you've onto Scott sure
I love scatting we ebdb what are you
doing oh I'm [ __ ] on just I'm
[ __ ] on your chest scat is the
scientific word for [ __ ]
Jesus you want to go scouting oh yeah I
love it okay cool come with me oh why we
going in your bedroom I'm gonna do [ __ ]
on your chest whoa whoa I thought we
were just gonna do nonsense and
vocalizing all right we couldn't do that
- go ahead yeah bleep bleep bleep or go
ahead so go ahead say down some
syllables get down here just keep it up
keep it up
oh boy you have [ __ ] on your chest
woopsy day see you Scott scene
that's what you deserve [ __ ] on your
chest cuz that's nothing you took
everything about jazz made it bad
there's books about scatting probably
you know like books
yeah don't scat unless unless you're
into [ __ ] on someone's chest and you
German and they like it too then very
cool very cool man guess if I'm sweaty
or not very sweaty why don't we go and
look at some of these hashtags huh why
don't we go and look at some of these
[ __ ] hashtags should we do instead I
don't want to I don't really feel like
doing Instagram well I'm gonna look at
what I had I didn't I didn't I know some
of you guys were upset I didn't do an
Instagram post of the week almost [ __ ]
up and we just got the last one I've
been oh you know let's just talk about a
blanket you know what it's time for the
most [ __ ] up Instagram post of the
week so what I feel like is well let's
do this one here's here it is now the
picture is of a female she is in like a
bodysuit
covering her [ __ ] with her hand even
though I can't see it because the
bodysuit and this is the caption some
first of all she's got a few a few tens
thousands of followers okay so she
thinks what she's saying is very
important important smart impresses me
strength of character impresses me but
most of all I'm impressed by kindness
kindness I think comes from learning
hard lessons well from falling and
picking yourself up I mean what a bunch
of [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] this is
oh yeah is that what you think kindness
comes from Oh kindness comes from
learning hard lessons well and falling
and picking yourself up sounds like
[ __ ] boxing you idiot it comes it
comes from surviving failure and loss I
mean no it doesn't there's people who
fail and lose that are complete [ __ ]
monger like pieces of [ __ ] that are rude
and it implies an understanding of the
human condition
no doesn't forgives its many flaws and
quirks when I see that in someone it
fills me with admiration hey nobody
gives a [ __ ] you know it doesn't matter
you what you're saying people don't look
to you the the egotistical nature of
that's what fills me with admiration the
egotistical [ __ ] nature of that
that's what fills me with admiration and
you're not Tony Robbins and Tony Robbins
let me do that [ __ ]
he's somebody with a few thousand
Instagram followers buy the whole
[ __ ] thing is ego man yeah brutal
brutal brutal let's go to some let's go
to this [ __ ] thing you guys seen it
yet I want to see it how much would it
would a [ __ ] guy in high school think
it's funny to say have you seen it and
somebody would be like what you'd be
like have you seen it and he's like
trying to play a joke on him like cuz
that's what the movie is called but he
would say it like that so you wouldn't
know that would be some [ __ ] like
somebody would do in my high school and
I'd be like god I hate this [ __ ] guy
have you seen it
oh all right let's
look at these congratulate see who's
gaming the system babies
congratulations pod congratulations
here we go and ask him that one coolest
this is from Amanda at a wala underscore
all right coolest lamest ways to die
it's funny she wrote lamest you know and
not worst like like who the [ __ ] would
die and be like yeah that was so lame
I guess lamest way to die would be like
slipping and falling because that would
be lame right but like worst coolest
coolest way to die I mean with
sunglasses on you know and having them
stay on even though you were [ __ ]
like I don't know I've been watching a
little bit of Game of Thrones and it
seems like everybody like wants honor
when they die [ __ ] no hey you know you
know how many people [ __ ] themselves
when they're killed a lot that's not
honorable
Ishay self lamest worst ways to die I
always thought like I mean there's so
many bad ones burned alive drowning you
know yeah weird question man you know
hey lifetime Devin de Matteo at Devin
Devin de Matteo hey lifetime baby here I
mean you know this podcast started 32
weeks ago lifetime baby thoughts on
people with hydraulics on in their cars
I suppose yeah I mean I don't know you
know everything in every culture has
their show off [ __ ] and like if you're a
I guess was it was it like I feel like
it like it was hip hop kind of [ __ ] that
was doing the hydraulics stuff first I
mean it's all stupid all of them it's
kind of at least it's like funny though
you know to see a guy like in his car
while it's [ __ ]
sing up and down literally like really
[ __ ] hard and to think that he's in
there going like like sanic gangster
you know hell yeah and he's so sideways
yeah I mean hydraulics I mean with the
little wheels is so [ __ ] too
with the little wheels like the [ __ ] um
what else what else was another one
what's that what's that one go up oh
that is gross man Bob Biggles at Biggles
Bob what do you think of people who eat
bags and more bags of bacon beef jerky
here's the thing man are you if you're
eating beef jerky you probably got it
from a gas station and you're on a road
trip what are you do what do you do what
is that that's not meat it's not me I
don't give a [ __ ]
beef jerky out of a bag like where is
your life that you're eating beef jerky
out of the bag remember when I was a kid
and someone told me that it some was
called beef jerky I laughed for a long
time jerky you know if don't put
something jerky in your mouth yeah oh
let's see oh I obviously hate this Ryan
Burch at Ryan with a no how do you feel
about people who refer to their favorite
sports teams as we like they play for
the team they're [ __ ] betas they're
betas see yeah you you're that you
literally sign your life over to another
man your gear you're one of those guys
in Game of Thrones that's like I wish to
serve you may I serve you
that's you you that's you that's you
you're a guy with a bit part that's you
oh look at this guy Marty Barrett at
Marty underscore barrack when was the
last time you were legitimately scared
be it for your life or maybe a spooky
movie
what the [ __ ] says spooky but his guide
can't be American and he's from Los
Angeles hey don't say spooky scariest
movie I've ever seen was called um I
always forget the name it was a Japanese
horror movie
they remade it with Kristen Bell I think
what the [ __ ] was it called look it up
they had this music on it that was
because I always think of purge it
something like purge but it's not that
obviously that was the Ethan Hawke [ __ ]
but what no not that it wasn't that not
The Grudge but it had this music on it
that was so scary is about like and and
the music would just be like this
[ __ ] note this one little thing sat
what it's called and it would go
hmm and that's it but the Japanese
version of pulse hmm dude I watch this
[ __ ] movie and I felt I was so scared
I felt it in my in my in my bowels like
I literally felt like oh this is what it
would be like to [ __ ] yourself and and
it takes its time and there are some
wide shots that are so [ __ ] scary you
know how in American cinema they'll do
the scary things are paying Bam Bam and
they'll show you real close this [ __ ]
they'll do it'll be like long shots I
guess is what the technical tour watch I
don't know wide shots of like scary [ __ ]
of like people like ghosts walking
towards you dude it's so scary I
literally watched it I watched some of
the parts with like I'd look at the side
of the screen
the side of the screen and [ __ ] held
up the [ __ ] blanket I was watching it
and and the music dude it's like
mmm it was terrifying that's all that
would do
mmm I don't even know what Irene
remember what it was about anymore by
far the scariest movie I've ever seen if
that movie was scary at a 10
the next scariest movie I've ever seen
was 7 that's how scary this [ __ ]
movie is watch it dude that's my
recommendation watch that movie I don't
know where you'll get probably I'll
watch it on like some weird [ __ ] app
that you can only get in Japan you know
it'll be on thing like my brother would
be like you have the scatter app you'd
be like what like yeah you watch movies
on the scatter app I'm like I'm not
getting a whole [ __ ] app so I can
watch eternal [ __ ] sunshine of the
spotless mind or whatever the hell is
called anyway yeah remember what I said
was
mMmmm it's so scary it's so [ __ ]
scary mmm
pulse go look at it and let me know
watch it I'm based on my recommendation
that's a cult that's some cult duty
watch it and then [ __ ] get back to me
I want to know if you thought it was
[ __ ] scary too and tell me what it's
about - like quickly like penis synopsis
because I don't really get it when I
will read the [ __ ]
alright well [ __ ] man I think that we're
gonna wrap this up you guys I got some
stuff to mention here blue apron you got
to check out this week's menu and get
your first three meals free with free
shipping by going to blue apron dot-com
/ Congrats remember that blue apron com
/ Congrats square cash have you switched
yet download the free square cash app or
IO for iOS or Android now and do that
with me so yeah I've got some upcoming
shows polos up uh and if you haven't
seen a man on fire that'd be great
go watch man on fire on Netflix if you
haven't watched it I don't know how you
can call yourself a baby if you haven't
watched men on fire yet but yet do that
and share it with your friends it'd be
great more and more people are watching
it it's awesome
my crowds are getting bigger and bigger
on the road which are awesome I
appreciate you coming out everyone
coming out and and and watching a live
show see my new my new material see my
new material recently recently uh
upcoming shows so you can see that this
week I'll be in New Brunswick New Jersey
Boone North Carolina I'm coming out I
think that's a Appalachian State
University yeah then Charlotte North
Carolina Adelaide Australia Perth
Melbourne Sydney Brisbane Columbus
Irvine oh that I'm sorry cut those were
go up those were uh Brisbane was
Australia and then Columbus Ohio
Irvine California San Jose California
get your tickets now they're selling out
um even far down like Irvine is tough to
get tickets for and San Jose I noticed
there were a lot of them and those are
in December so there's few tickets left
so do that and rate and review and tweet
me
rate and review the podcast please that
really helps tell your friends about it
make your friends listen to it in the
car and try to build this cult man let's
let's be that let's let's do it you got
to listen to [ __ ] you gotta listen
you gotta be out of you gotta help help
me out here
so thank you Chris D'Elia calm or
congratulations pod calm on my websites
and tweet meet Congrats pod and also use
the hashtag hashtag congratulations pod
thanks very much you guys are the [ __ ]
sayonara my babies